civil war in Syria could be entering its
final chapter but several obstacles
remain before any victory over the
terrorists could be declared in etad
where Americans have a military base new
u.s. exercises have been launched
unannounced our forces will demonstrate
the capability to deploy rapidly assault
to target with integrated air and ground
forces and conducts rapid exfiltration
anywhere in the operation inherent
resolve combined joint operations area
that's after Russia informed the u.s. of
its pursuit of terrorists into a
so-called deconfliction zone the
russians informed the US and september
the first by the deconfliction line that
they intended to enter the at 10:50
confliction zone to pursue terrorists
the russians indicated by written note
in September the 6th that they would
make precision strikes in the at 10th
deconfliction zone against terrorists no
comment about the note from Russia so
far the u.s. though assured Russia
there's no intent for conflict with the
pro Syrian government forces but they
will retaliate to any hostile actions so
what's the purpose of these military
maneuvers exercises like this both the
odds of feet Isis capabilities and
ensure that we are ready to respond to
any threat to our forces and the
widening war on terror has long been
Washington's go-to justification for
sticking it out in Syria even boosting
numbers on the ground with the end of
the campaign in sight we're gonna stay
for several reasons stabilization and
assistance in the vital north and
northeast protection of our allies to
identify those responsible for using
chemical weapons in Syria to pursue a
diplomatic resolution be a part of what
would be a widening effort across the
world to achieve a political settlement
to set the conditions for the United
Nations backed Geneva process to succeed
America does not seek an indefinite
presence in Syria under no circumstance
when America talks about terror its
position is the fact
that have been making resistance against
American hegemony in the region then
actually the problem you've got is
America's plans are being you know
destroyed and billions and trillions of
dollars are being wasted so America of
course it's very very friend
it's very scared because this was
completely indirectly against its own
interests in it lib the last remaining
terrorist stronghold fighting between
the world and extremist groups has been
put on hold the consequences of a major
offensive operation in Italy will almost
certainly be the suffering of a large
number of innocent civilians Washington
says it's got its own way to deal with
terrorism in Syria they say they will be
better and more focused but details
haven't been very forthcoming
at any rate Moscow is out of the picture
when it comes to Syria and that's
despite Russia recently meeting with
other players to the conflict Turkey and
Iran they came up with a joint statement
that put forward a political solution to
the conflict leaders from those
countries agreed the only path forward
is for unconditional terrorists
surrender Turkey though is against any
operation enid lib calling for a
ceasefire if we declare a ceasefire this
will be a victory for the summit and the
most important step in the process will
give peace of mind to civilians Russian
President Vladimir Putin said ceasefire
or not the terrorists there are
unpredictable and Turkey well they've
reportedly already advanced towards it
Lib there are many people stirring the
pot in Syria the reality is that
actually it's only two factions there's
a faction that is against genuinely
against terrorism the main country of
course is Syria but you've got Russia
and Iran giving it a lot of good support
and on the other side you've got
everyone else who is dancing for reasons
better known to them to the sturdy
TuneIn to the tune of Washington
actually the solution for Syria is very
simple let the terrorists be finished
let them go and when you have standard
normal democratic elections
Arty's Arabic Channel spoke with a
former Iranian defense minister to get
his
thoughts on the current situation in
Syria the US and Israel only follow
their own interests and goals to achieve
those they use the cover of chemical
weapons accusations the US and Israel
skew world public opinion through a
destructive information war the only
chance for the countries is to address
the UN where they constantly face an
American veto the u.s. follows the law
of the jungle when it comes to Syria and
the world in general Americans and
Israelis do not care about civilian
casualties I will never forget one u.s.
general boarding an American ship in the
Persian Gulf and stating Iranian people
do not deserve to live on this land
first of all we need to eliminate the
danger Italy poses to Aleppo Hama Homs
and Damascus it shouldn't be accepted
that terrorists possessing different
kinds of weapons have resettled to some
other city
secondly we need to separate terrorist
groups from the armed opposition so that
the latter could fight the terrorists
together with the Syrian government
you